hello and welcome to this video in this
video I'm going to show you some details
about the latest release on chess about
my latest book keep it simple money for
ya what is that actually it's a full
repertoire white money form is the first
move in this repertoire and we are
covering all the lines that black may
play from the Sicilian to the French to
1e5 everything is included and why is it
called keep it simple there are two
reasons or two points where keep it
simple is a fitting motto first of all I
wanted to choose variations that are
relatively easy to learn so there is not
an open Sicilian in there or there isn't
something in there which is crazy
complicated that like depending on one
single line that you have to know how to
move 30 or something and these some kind
of approaches I think are very
unpractical so I wanted to do something
that is relatively simple and easy to
learn remember maintain the second thing
is the type of variations are often not
super forcing they don't have super long
technical lines there are exceptions of
course especially if black plays
something unsound you sometimes simply
need to punish it as severely as
possible and then a technical and
complicated line is in order but in
general I want to go for lines that
should you get it on the board and you
have this moment that we all know that
oh my god I forgotten what I wanted to
play if this moment pops up you should
find yourself in a position where you
know roughly what to do and then can
find a good move over the board this is
where keep it simple and kicks in I also
want to mention that the idea of doing
an e4 repertoire was born um yeah while
working with my chest students there is
a
of course a huge variety of opening
preferences I have chest students that
play and an opening repertoire that is
somewhat similar to my own like more d4c
493 but I also have some students who
play 1e form and they like those
positions and I feel it's totally fine
for them to play you for and for those
students I simply need to know things to
recommend and what I wanted to recommend
to many of them is an easy solution
something that is good to learn and this
is how I chose those variations I also
find myself often in the position that I
need to recommend something to a person
to a student who is going to play a game
let's say tomorrow and they tell me you
know my opponent plays this and that
show me something that you can easily
explain to me and I've chosen lines in
this book that you can explain to people
rather quickly it's not like yeah you
play the open Sicilian and whatever
there's all kinds of things that could
happen it is more easily learned and
maintained let's have a look once we
open this up here on chasuble um what
did what it contains well going to
browse we see we have ten chapters here
we have ten chapters and we have a
forty-five we have the Sicilian and so
on everything is included that could pop
up so it's a fully for rapid one now we
should talk a little bit about how that
works on chesil if you have already used
chasuble as a learning and training
platform some of the things won't be new
to you at all yeah you know what what
happens let's say what is the difference
between learning on chasuble to learning
with the traditional paper book or
learning with an e-book like a PDF or
something like that then difference is
that here you actually you get you get
to see the variations and you get to
repeat them so I'm going to show you
just show an example what I've done is
by the way this is this has been on
chasuble to test for for me and some
better testers for for two weeks and
I've actually learned my whole
repertoire using chasuble again so I've
repeated every single position and
learned it yeah you can see that here
from the leaderboard that and
second-place zoo controls ghost is even
before me ahead of me but I've gone
through everything but now you see there
are some new buttons here which means
they have been some variations added in
recently on those variations they have
been added during the better testing
phase so I want to learn something new
so I open up something here let's simply
click learn next and it will show me a
variations start move trainer it will
show me a variation that I have not yet
studied before aha so here it tells me
black plays c5 and I say c3 this is the
most practical choice so you can read it
as a book but what you have to do now is
it actually asks you what should you
play and okay we have just seen c3 was
my recommended reply and you can put
your put that on the board two or three
times and then it says okay progress
saved you learn that and then you click
next lesson and you get the next
position shown to you like yeah okay B
should be three and you can read of
course the text here and the great thing
is if you make a mistake and I'm going
to make a mistake now on purpose I'm
doing something stupid yeah let's do
this this is very stupid and it says
incorrect and it shows it okay yeah yeah
okay neither three is right and what was
that again but should be three I'll do
that no incorrect so okay so it just
checks what is right and tells you what
what you're doing wrong but the great
thing is it actually saves all those
points where you failed and it will
repeat them for you it will show you
where you failed and then step by step
you will be will get better and
memorizing everything this is the basic
way how this move trainer works it shows
you the moves you will repeat them and
you it really help
to remember them because you get to see
it more than once and you have to put
those pieces on the board like the
virtual board it really helps
tremendously now what is new in this
release because this technology was
untestable
before of course what is new with this
release is the inclusion of video this
is the big novelty here if you look it
on the right hand side it says paid
video and free video if you add that up
because we've released one chapter for
free and some previews this is what the
free video means the overall video time
is 17 hours roughly 17 hours where I'm
going to show you every single move in
the lights this is some this is the big
use here with this repertoire how does
that work yeah and let's um we can we
can choose any line let's go into the
Sicilian we have the video screen here
and now you can use that in more than
one way you can simply watch the video
like you watch a movie if you like and
I'm going to switch off the sound it's
very irritating of the sound it's like
doubled yeah so we have the video here
and you can just watch it if you like
yeah this is a how long is that in
particular it's I think it's close to
two hours him I guess you can watch it
just like you watch a movie I'm going to
show them show the lines I'm going to
tell you how it should be played and now
what exactly is the the new thing here
you can Envy no video on chess the thing
is that it is very nicely combined with
the variations that you learn in the
Move trainer so you see here there's a
filter filter variations based on video
position and the video position here I
can jump to any position that some
somewhere yeah and it will filter out
the precise variation that this position
is from so you can actually watch the
video I can pause it now and you can
filter this
out and then jump into it and then use
it can you you can read the prose and
actually repeat the whole thing again
this is extremely useful because you can
easily get to the spots that are
interested that are interesting for you
but if you okay I wasn't so sure about
that when you see the video for example
and you feel hmm what about this and
that idea and this and that move then
you can easily go here and here you have
all the additional possibilities what
you can do is for example you can
analyze it with an engine you have the
FE end string here the position string
that you can copy and paste into other
tools like any analysis engine that you
might have on your computer you can also
and this is an excellent feature you can
post a comment on on a particular
position and ask a question and those
questions will be answered by either
another user or by me I do regularly
check the comments and post them answers
to them sometimes just a verbal answer
is four completely fine and sometimes
there's a suggestion that is so
interesting then I'm actually changing
the book so it is a living product um
just to show and what I'm talking about
how that would work out you can go on
position comments and here's some of the
better testers actually he gave me some
feedback like for example this in that
position what about this and that move
and so on and I've added those
suggestions so you can if you jump to
discussion here for example here Zucco
tones go was posted okay what about this
and that move and this is for example a
move Bishop g4 that I've really add to
the repertoire I haven't done yet but I
will do and so this is a living
repertoire it grows and it gets better
even as it progresses because the input
by the user by potentially by you will
improve the product and you get
questions answered when you really feel
Oh what is that is that a move then you
just go go here and you you ask
and you will get help this is really
really excellent
what's also possible with any video is
the opportunity to go from a position to
go from a position that you have in a
variation back to the video so it's the
other way around for example let me jump
into into the car oh here um here it's a
filter early on in a position I've been
to that video before obviously and it's
an early position so there are many many
variations here and you can go the other
way around so I can actually click here
on that little video button and then it
gives you the video on that variation
this is a very helpful feature because
especially when you face situations
where you tend to forget the moves you
can watch the video again so to make an
example of that where do I go because
I've definitely had problems with the
odd variation and I've written the book
but it can happen that I simply miss
misclicked or simply put a put out a
wrong move it just happens
so what just about does here for example
tells you difficult move mistakes we
strongly recommend that I study this
yeah so I must have made a mistake
somewhere when I repeated the line and
and then I could just pick here and
again watch the video again and that
maybe helps to clarify what was so
difficult about the move to learn so the
video integrates nicely into the
learning experience I think it's really
excellent excellently done yeah so you
get you get the traditional chasuble
interactive ebook with all the learning
benefits that you get from the
technology plus the video you can you
can
just buy them what we call book just the
how the move trainer works as you know
it and you can buy the additional video
it's your choice the video is an
excellent added value in 17 hours it's
just enormous ly helpful I think to to
learn so I hope you enjoyed the preview
of the product thanks for watching